you had a company that was broadcasting
on the internet right television stuff
audio and video so we've all the
streaming Everything YouTube does we
started that you started that it was
called audionet we started in 1995 and
when Yahoo bought you right they gave
you $2.5 billion no they gave us $5.7
billion in stock right and then so I got
33% of it or whatever right and then um
when Yahoo went to about 2 and a half
billion you sold everything when when it
went up I did a a hedge right they
called it one of the top 10 trades all
time on Wall Street what did you do so I
got all the stock from Yahoo and
everybody else thought the internet
bubble was going to keep on going
forever right I'm like there's no way so
I sold calls bought puts so I protected
my stock and so it went up in value some
more and went up to where my hedge was
and then cashed me out I see and then
the whole market cratered and I was
protected when you cashed out Yahoo went
up a little bit more and people said to
you oh aren't you sorry why didn't you
hold on you said I've got I've got 2 and
half billion how much do you need right
that's exactly and you didn't get greedy
I mean you could have kept saying I'll
stay in another day I'll stay in another
week and if you had waited just a couple
of weeks yeah probably about six weeks I
would have been [__] like how badly
[__] you might have lost a billion
dollars oh more than that more oh yeah
no Yahoo went from like $300 to like $5
it went from what to what like 300 to5
wow in a matter of weeks and probably
over the course of a year but you it
would have been impossible to really get
out right and and so some of the guys
were in business with you all got stock
as well did some of them stay in too
long and get tanked yeah I mean I I went
to everybody that were that owned stock
in the company I was I said do this do
this do this get out I'm getting out
protect yourself right protect yourself
right and some of them did but a lot of
them didn't wow they just got caught up
and oh there's some miserable friends
that I have and boy like the guys who
put in I was just talking to my partner
Todd Wagner just the other day actually
the guys who put in $330,000 ended up
with 30 million wow and some some of our
employees who were there right at the
beginning that we didn't have a lot of
money we gave them stock 15 20 25
million and a chunk of them just lost it
all W oh that's a shame what they worth
20 million one day that's it it's your
ticket to freedom and then zero nothing
you're searching for a job take it away
wow and you begged these guys you said
look even I who you were the major
stockholder right I was the largest
Stocker by far yeah you hit 2 and a half
billion and you said hey if I stay in
maybe I'll have five billion no yeah and
I told these guys come on now seriously
after the 2 and 1 half billion after
buying the Mavericks after blah blah
blah blah what are you worth today now
probably more than three cuz I've made
some good Investments wow yeah wowe yeah
it's crazy woe zoi it's crazy look at
you